DAVID FEUER: Hello, all.
And welcome to Dev 302, Building
and Managing GraphQL APIs.
I'm Dave Feuer, and I'm
joined by Greg Brail.
We're a part of the Apigee team.
And we're super excited to
present this to you today.
GREGORY BRAIL: Hey, I'm Greg.
I'm also part of
the Apigee team.
And I'm also excited.
DAVID FEUER: I guess the first
thing I wanted to get out
of the way is that
sometimes, in technology,
we can overemphasize how new
technologies and exciting ideas
are dominant in
the conversation.
And so I just wanted to be
clear-- and I think both Greg
and I share-- that REST
is still the king of APIs.
If you look at this graph,
which is from Google Trends,
it clearly shows that REST
is still the king of APIs
and still dominates interest.
And so while we're here to
talk to you about GraphQL
and some other API
styles, it's important
that we realize that REST still
has a very important and very
prominent position in
building and designing
APIs for the future.
If we're going to contrast
GraphQL and REST APIs,
I think there's three
specific areas that we'd
want to talk to you about.
The first is that both GraphQL
and REST offer a consistent way
to access different
types of data.
So while GraphQL and REST
construct things differently
and construct requests
differently and get responses
differently, fundamentally, they
both allow you to access data.
GraphQL offers a query
language that's different,
of course, than the
REST query style.
And that can potentially work
across many types of back ends.
But fundamentally, they're
both requesting data,
and they're both offering
a consistent access
pattern for the data.
The second is efficiency.
While it's possible to construct
REST APIs in an efficient way,
GraphQL is specifically
built to avoid
over-fetching or
under-fetching data.
The query language
is super powerful
and allows you to
request just the data you
need for your client, whether
it's a mobile client, a web
client, or another
style of application.
And the last is
implementation complexity.
Implementing an HTTP server
to parse URLs and return
data from a variety of sources,
that's a straightforward task.
And many people do that in
their environments today.
But GraphQL requires specific
software and a specific engine
on the server side that
can parse the queries
and break them down
into execution steps.
And so that's a
significant difference
between GraphQL and REST.
To recap some of the
benefits of GraphQL,
I think data load control
and granularity are
super important.
The fact that GraphQL
has a single endpoint
and allows you to really
execute one request
and then have the fan-out
on the southbound side
make a whole bunch of
subsequent requests
and return that, it's
very, very powerful.
It also means that if
one resolves or fails,
other queries can still
succeed and still resolve
and bring back useful data.
In the REST world, REST doesn't
necessarily work that way.
REST has multiple
different endpoints.
And so each query
to each endpoint
has to be treated individually.
GREGORY BRAIL: So could
you maybe talk a little bit
about, as a software engineer,
maybe I'm building an app.
Why would I choose GraphQL,
and why would I choose REST?
DAVID FEUER: Great,
great question.
I think there's a lot
of apps-- specifically,
apps built using the ReactJS
framework-- that really benefit
from the fact that
GraphQL will only
get the data that's in view.
So that for
instance, if you were
tracking sports
statistics, you only
retrieve the sports
statistics for the player
that you're looking
at, or you only
receive the sports statistics
for the specific table
that you can view
in a mobile app.
As opposed to REST,
which might require
additional APIs or
additional parameters
to accommodate all
the different views
that might exist in an app
and create individual APIs
for those different views.
So being able to leverage
the GraphQL query
language to really only
get the data that you need
for that specific user creates
a certain amount of efficiency
and a certain amount of
developer safety, where
they know they're getting the
data that they expect when they
expect it, versus having to
make multiple calls in order
to fill out whatever
table the user
might choose to view
in that application.
Does that make sense?
GREGORY BRAIL: Yeah.
So with REST, I'm used to using
an API gateway like Apigee,
where I might have a couple of
customized versions of my API
for different devices
because I want
to have it be more efficient.
Are you saying, with
GraphQL, I have more options,
I have more
flexibility in the data
that I return to my client?
DAVID FEUER: Absolutely.
Along with the control
that gives you the ability
to request exactly what you want
and retrieve exactly the data
you want also comes a tremendous
amount of responsibility,
right?
Suddenly, you have to figure
out up front what data you want,
versus simply calling an API.
That being said,
with that control
comes a certain amount of
developer safety, as we said,
where calling that
one API just becomes
very simple and very easy.
And that query
language is really
what provides that control
in the GraphQL world.
GREGORY BRAIL: So
a mobile developer
might really like
the fact that they
can choose exactly
what they want,
send one request to the server,
and get it all back at once,
rather than having to navigate a
whole forest of individual URLs
in order to get the
same information.
DAVID FEUER: Absolutely.
Yeah, that's a
great point, Greg.
The third point is that
whereas in the past,
GraphQL required a whole
bunch of specific glue
in order to work with
different programming
languages and
different frameworks,
we're really seeing a
proliferation of GraphQL client
libraries.
So GraphQL really is available
as a polyglot protocol,
and is no longer simply
reduced to a few languages
or a few frameworks.
GraphQL is really fairly
open and really portable.
And so we're seeing a change,
a shift, in adoption of GraphQL
as a result of that.
So I think if we
take a step back,
we'll see that there are
really two communities of use
for APIs.
There are API
programs, which are
tight-knit teams where
the client and server are
tight-knit group.
Or sometimes, they're
the same person
that's developing both
the server application
and the client application.
And then, there are
developer programs,
which are really about
creating APIs as products,
and exposing those APIs to
those different communities
so that different developers
can build their own front
ends of their own
application servers
that leverage your APIs
to create different value
propositions.
So in that specific instance,
it could be a different business
unit.
It could be a different company.
It can be a partner.
But you no longer
have the same scope
of control over both the
server and the client.
And that's a significant change.
But that's a significant
difference between API programs
and developer programs,
that in API programs,
you really don't have
to be as strict about
design of your API.
Because since you control
the client and the server,
you can assume a certain
amount of knowledge,
and mediate between
that on your own.
But when you have a
developer program,
the clients don't
know what you know.
And so you have to make
sure to actually productize
your API in such
a way that makes
it discoverable and
accessible and makes
it easy for
developers to leverage
and consume that API
in order to drive
business value not just for you,
but also for their application.
GREGORY BRAIL: So if
I'm using GraphQL,
how do I know a
developer is not going
to do something crazy
and query a bunch of data
they aren't supposed to get?
DAVID FEUER: Exactly.
Greg, perfect setup.
I think that's the fundamental
challenge, is that we don't.
We don't know what
clients are going to do.
In REST, we know
what APIs we expose.
And so we know what clients
are going to request,
because that's what the API is.
The API exposes that resource.
In GraphQL, when you're
exposing all of your resources,
like a graph, clients can really
request whatever they want.
And so we're seeing GraphQL
struggling in that area,
in the area of developer
programs, where it's been super
popular with API programs.
And I think what we're doing
with Apigee is super exciting
here, in taking all the
learnings that we've
had from productization
of APIs and bringing them
over to GraphQL.
Greg, why don't you
talk a little bit
about API productization and how
we're bringing that to GraphQL?
GREGORY BRAIL: Awesome, thanks.
So if we look at
this chart, this
talks about a lot of the
things that an API team
needs to think
about when they're
trying to turn an
API into a product,
taking something that's just
an HTTP endpoint with some JSON
and turn it into
something that developers
from different organizations
and different companies
can consume.
And a lot of these
things are things
that if you've been following
the world of API management
or seen in the
Apigee things before,
you've probably heard of
about a lot of these things.
Timing to First Hello,
World, for instance--
that's what that
acronym is for--
is a really important
metric for an API program
if you want developers
to adopt your API.
Having a community, having
standards, like oAuth,
as part of your API, and having
things like developer portals.
And this enables, really, one
of the most important things
that's a difference
between an API
used by a small team and a
developer program used by lots
of developers and
different organizations,
is the ability to
do self-service.
And when we talk about
API productization,
a big part of it
is self service.
How does a developer who
wants to use your API
find out about the API,
figure out what the API does,
and get credentials?
If they can do that
in a few minutes,
your API is ready
for consumption
by almost anyone in the world.
And that applies
whether your API
is a REST API of the style we've
been talking about for years
and years in the world of API
management or a GraphQL API.
Now, when we talk about this,
we talk about control, security,
observability, and governance.
And in the world of
REST APIs, we often
do a lot of these things based
on the fundamental principles
of REST, like URLs and verbs.
We'll do things like,
we'll say, if you've
got credentials for
the API, you are
authorized to invoke certain
URLs, but not other URLs.
Or perhaps you're authorized
to get all the URLs,
but if you want to
post some of the URLs,
you need a different
kind of credentials.
All of these same things are
going to apply to GraphQL.
We're going to ask a lot
of these same questions.
So when David talked about
making a GraphQL API ready
for consumption by
developers, the developers
will love it, because
now I can do anything.
I have access to
your whole schema.
I can query all kinds of stuff.
And I can build a great app.
And what I've said for years
and years about this stuff
is that it's not just that you
have to worry about an attacker
or someone who's malicious.
You also have to
worry about people
who just make mistakes, right?
Like, oh, I didn't realize
that by executing that GraphQL
query, I would download 10,000
rows of data from the database
and clog up the internet and
make my mobile device crash.
Now, I know that.
So I know I have to
include a parameter.
But wouldn't it be nice if
we could put some controls
in front of the GraphQL API,
so a developer can't even
do that sort of
thing by accident?
So what we're
doing at Apigee is,
we're starting on a
journey of figuring out
what we need to
do to make GraphQL
APIs the same kind of
first-class APIs as the REST
APIs and the other kinds of
APIs that Apigee traditionally
supports.
So in the traditional
world of API management,
we have this chart where we
have API teams build APIs,
developers build apps for APIs
to create user experiences
for end users.
And that transition from
an API used by an API team
to a developer program is
what this is all about.
The question is, when we
are working with GraphQL,
how does this differ from the
way it looks for a REST API?
And the answer
is, not very much.
All of the same
principles apply.
The developer wants
to be able to discover
the API via self-service.
They want to get credentials.
They want to use the API.
The API team wants
to have control
over who's allowed
to use their API
and how much they're
allowed to use the API.
Are they allowed to use
different parts of the API
for different purposes?
Is there a quota that stops them
from using the API too much?
Are there security
rules or audit rules?
Is there even a billing plan
associated with that API?
We want to be able to
do all of these things
for GraphQL APIs, which means
that we have to not only look
at URLs and verbs, but we
have to look at the structure
of the GraphQL query.
And we have to understand,
when you make a query, what
is this query trying to do?
And as an API team,
what kind of things
can I let the developers do?
And you can do this by having
lots of different GraphQL
endpoints.
But one of the advantages
of an API management system
is that it allows
the API team to be
very sophisticated in turning
those APIs into products.
So if they want to launch with
an API that does five things
and sell it to customers for
a certain price or for free.
But then, they want to
add two more things,
but they only want
certain customers
to be able to do those things.
And then, they want
to add one more thing
that only a few
customers can see,
but no one else
should find out about.
You can do all of this in
your API management product
without changing
your API at all.
You do this by restricting.
In Apigee, you do this
by creating something,
something called an API product.
And an API product
basically specifies
which parts of the API are
available to which kind
of consumers, what
kind of quotas on them.
And we can attach
additional data to it
that we can use to
make other decisions.
We want to do those same sorts
of things with GraphQL APIs.
So if you look at what
we've added to Apigee,
Apigee now has a way,
inside any Apigee proxy,
to parse a GraphQL request.
First of all, just to reject
it if it's invalid, or even
do schema validation.
That can be super
valuable, because it
means that if you have malicious
users or developers who
are still learning the
API and making mistakes,
Apigee can nip all of
those invalid requests
right in the Apigee
proxy, and not
even let them get to your
back-end server, which takes
a load off your GraphQL engine.
But Apigee can now
parse that query,
understand what it's trying
to do, and make decisions.
So a very simple thing you
could do, for instance,
is say that certain developers
or certain applications
are only allowed
to execute queries
against the GraphQL API.
Whereas you have to have a
different kind of credential
and, possibly,
approval from the API
team in order to make mutations.
Which means, basically,
we can very easily
separate the read only API
from the read or write API.
And then, we can do more.
And I think what we're
doing in the future is,
we're looking at
what more we can do.
So for instance, we also,
now that we understand
the shape of the API, we can
put a bunch of information
into the Apigee message flow.
We can then use other policies
to make other decisions.
So it gives a lot of
flexibility for you
as a developer, right now, to
build some interesting GraphQL
API-related access control
and other decision-making
logic into your Apigee proxy.
And it's going to
make it possible
for us to do even more
with this in the future.
DAVID FEUER: And Greg,
do you see this affecting
how enterprises are
able to position
GraphQL APIs for consumption?
Like, is this
something that you see
helping application developers
build new experiences using
GraphQL APIs?
GREGORY BRAIL: Yeah.
So if you're an application--
I mean, you and I have
been around the world
a little while.
Once upon a time, it was
considered terribly bad form
to expose your relational
database directly
to developers.
Because developers
might be able to do
something like select
star from customers--
or worse yet, delete
and overwhelm the database, or
execute some ridiculous query
that is nested 17 levels deep
and joins 12 different tables
together and slows down the
application for everybody.
So that's where three-tier
computing and transaction
processing monitors and
all these things came in.
Same thing with GraphQL.
If you just put a GraphQL API
in front of your core data
and give access to developers
to get at it directly,
then you have to have some
trust in your developers
that they're not going
to execute queries that
cause performance problems or
security problems or compliance
problems.
So if you have something sitting
in front of that GraphQL API
that's able to
look at the queries
and make decisions about what's
allowed and what's not allowed,
I think it makes it
easier for an enterprise
to be OK with the idea of using
GraphQL for critical data.
DAVID FEUER: Awesome.
GREGORY BRAIL: And with
that, we have a demo.
You're going to listen to me.
And what we're going
to do is, we're
going to show some of the new
GraphQL features of Apigee
and what we can do with them.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I'm going to start with an
example of a mobile application
that uses GraphQL.
This application is
a product catalog.
And it makes one API call to
get the product information,
plus an API call for every price
and every stock information.
So as you can see, when
I refresh the screen,
we have a lot of
these blue circles
that show API calls being made.
And when I click on
an individual product,
we make three API calls
to get the result.
However, I can also
switch my application
to take advantage of GraphQL.
In that case, it makes one
API call to my back end.
It's querying the exact
same database tables.
In my case, it's even
calling the exact same gRPCs.
But the mobile app is sending
one request to the back end.
And the back end is
fanning all of that
and returning one response.
The result is quite a
bit more responsive.
There's only one API call
required to get all the product
information I need.
When I scroll up and
down, it's nice and zippy.
And there's none of that
refreshing going on.
So as you can see, GraphQL
can be a very effective way
to make an efficient
and snappy mobile app.
Now that we've
looked at the app,
let's actually see what's
going on with the API
under the covers.
Underneath, of course,
I have a GraphQL API.
And I can do some
things in this GraphQL
API, like, for instance,
got a list of products.
And like in all
good GraphQL APIs,
I can merge data from
different data sets.
I can sort.
I can decide how many.
And I can get information
about an individual product.
And once again, I can
decide exactly what fields
I want to see or don't see.
And on this particular case,
this particular GraphQL query
is being secured
via an API key which
is being enforced by Apigee.
Using this particular
API key, I can also
try and get information
about the price of an item.
And if I use that key, here's
my query to get the price.
You'll see that I get an error.
This is coming from Apigee.
Because Apigee parsed the query.
It saw that the
top-level selection
set was called "price."
And this particular API key is
not allowed to make that query.
However, if I change
the API key to an API
key that uses a
different API product,
I now can get the price.
Now that we've seen
with the API looks
like, let's see how
it works in Apigee.
First of all, Apigee has
always had API products.
They're key to API management,
because they let you package up
an API without changing the back
end into different combinations
of functionality,
different quota settings,
and even different
aspects, like security,
depending on who's
consuming the API.
We've added GraphQL
support to API products.
So now, in addition to filtering
on URL paths and verbs,
like we could
before, we can also
filter on, for instance,
the GraphQL operation type,
like whether it's a
query or mutation.
And we can set different
quotas for different products,
like we always could.
So for instance,
you could set it up
so a certain API key or a
certain set of applications
that use oAuth might be
allowed only to do queries.
Or they might have a different
quota than another set.
And they might
even be restricted
based on the name of
the GraphQL operation.
Now, the way this is enforced
is in the proxy, of course.
And we have the first part
of functionality to do this,
is our new GraphQL policy.
First thing it does is parse the
query to make sure it's valid.
It can also validate the
schema if you'd like.
And then, it sets a
bunch of variables
that we can use
for other things.
For instance, it's used
in the CheckAPIKey policy
to enforce the API product
logic that I just talked about.
I wanted to go a little
bit further in this demo
and use the name of the
selection set, which
is the top of that
query, to determine
which API keys could query which
parts of my GraphQL schema.
And I did that using
some JavaScript.
I set a variable
in the product that
specifies what top-level
selection sets are allowed.
And I use a variable that is
set by the GraphQL policy which
contains that information.
After that, a little
bit of error checking
follows, and some clever
but simple JavaScript
that simply looks to see if
the name of that selection set
is in the product.
That's all there is to it.
And now I'm able to have some
very interesting controls
on my GraphQL application.
[END PLAYBACK]
GREGORY BRAIL: So
we've just seen
a demo that shows how you
can use the new GraphQL
features of Apigee
to parse queries
and understand them, and
have additional logic
to make decisions about
those to make your API more
ready for the enterprise.
Over to you, Dave.
DAVID FEUER: Thanks, Greg.
That was awesome.
We're super excited about
GraphQL and our ability
to bring it to our customers
and prospects to build new apps
and experience with
this new technology.
Please go to
cloud.google.com/apigee to try
it out.
We'd love to hear
what you think.
Thanks for joining
us today, and have
a great rest of the summit.